president biden's supreme court nominee
judge katanji brown jackson facing a
marathon session of questions during her
confirmation hearing judge jackson being
pressed over her judicial philosophy
liberal beliefs and alleged soft on
crime stance republicans taking issue
with sentences she handed out for child
pornography cases
judges have to consider things like
the victims and when i was talking about
making sure that victims
circumstances are heard it was about my
sentencing practices
that that i could victims being heard
with respect
republicans promising to keep things
civil but saying there is a glaring
double standard at play
there are two standards going on here
if you're an african-american
conservative woman you're fair game to
have your life turned upside down to be
filibustered no matter how
qualified you are
and if you express your faith as a
conservative all of a sudden you're a
effing nut
and we're tired of it
and it's not going to happen to you
but it just appalls me
that we can have such a system in
america
all right just on clarification on that
so he was talking about janice rogers
brown she was the nominee for that
president bush 43 put forward and in
2005 and 2006 she was filibustered for
two years she was a black conservative
judge and there were
members of the senate at the time and
biden was on the judiciary committee who
did not want to put her forward because
one of the people said anonymously of
course to the paper that they did not
want a republican to be in a position to
nominate a black woman to the supreme
court because they wanted to do that
themselves that's what that was all
about she was a very qualified judge
miguel estrada same thing hispanic judge
this is in 2005 2006 and then those
nominations failed all right judge on
the
soft on crime issue or on judicial
philosophy what did you take away today
i think she still hasn't indicated what
her judicial philosophy is she talked
about her methodology and her method
she is so her methodology is unusual
number one she says she goes from a
position of impartiality and then she
hears the arguments from both sides and
then she decides well that's what every
judge does that's you know that's
nothing new but i'll tell you the thing
that bothers me is those who defend her
based upon her sentencing of the
consumers of child pornography as not
recommending by the way no mandatory
minimum and you know the fact is that
she talks about
victims but she doesn't really talk
about the fact that these young children
are forever
in a position of being living forever in
images of being sexually molested on the
internet among pornographers and her
position is well you know for the first
offender they really there shouldn't be
a mandatory incarceration that's her
judicial philosophy when she was on a
sentencing commission and she's gotten
away with that and i think it's a little
too easy and i don't like the fact that
you know she says i talk to the
defendants and tell them about the harm
talk about the victims who've really
suffered the harm and she continuously
goes through that and when the truth is
if you possess
uh child pornography
she doesn't want to sentence them to
time but if you receive it then the law
says you must give him a minimum but she
undercuts it i haven't heard anything
about her sentencing at the high end so
she is a classic public defender
uh did you want to answer that jessica
she's a
she's a public defender i mean that was
her job and that's how she sees things
and i don't think i think that the
attempt to have some sort of
conversation about judge jackson being
someone who
thinks in any way that
child pornography is okay or that it is
a huge injustice or something incredibly
terrible that happens to the kids that
are featured in this
is just a big failure i i today i just
saw a lot of people
talking about the things that they
wanted to talk about you know with the
crt talking about uh gitmo detainees
with john cornyn saying that you know
she said that
bush and rumsfeld were war criminals
when that's just how a habeas corpus
petition is actually filed that it says
the name of the defendant v
bush and then oh why did you call them
war criminals
you should know first of all how those
petitions work you should know that that
was just the formula it seemed like they
were trying to land a lot of uh big
booms or whatever you want to say it is
big booms and it just wasn't working
she's been very steady and i understand
it hasn't been an electrifying hearing
but she seems to be answering everyone's
questions and
on the child porn sentencing issue she
had several days to prepare an answer
she had a prepared one at the very
beginning let's go to call for number
one if you could this is her answering a
question from durbin i believe
there's a statute
that tells judges what they're supposed
to do congress has decided
what it is that a judge has to do in
this and any other case when they
sentence
and that statute
that statute doesn't say
look
only at the guidelines and stop
the statute doesn't say
impose
the highest possible penalty for this
sickening and egregious crime
the statute says
calculate the guidelines
but also look at
various aspects of this offense and
impose a sentence that is quote
sufficient but not greater than
necessary
and that's exactly the point that she is
looking at these cases as not meeting
even the minimum sentencing she is
indicating that congress didn't tell me
that i couldn't go below it so i'm going
to go below it that is not recognizing
the danger the harm the sickening nature
of what children are forced to do and
forced to live with throughout their
life with those photos being among child
pedophiles yeah and she did talk about
the victim statements and things like
that but jesse on this or on any of the
other other issues it hasn't been the
most
fireworks of any hearing we've seen in
the recent past no this is not the
kavanaugh hearing for sure
and if she wants to just blame congress
for everything then she should just run
for president because that's what
presidents do she's going to be a
supreme court justice that's a cop-out
blame congress judges have wide
discretion with regards to sentencing
and ted cruz held up a sheet with all
these cases of child pornography and
every single case she sentenced below
the guidelines and below what
prosecutors had requested
that's a pattern and that's a scary
pattern because why why would you
sympathize with people who possess child
pornography and when she was asked why
she says oh it's congress's fault that's
bs i'm also disturbed by she sympathizes
with gitmo terrorists now in the one
case she had to defend the guy because
she was a public federal defender i get
that but then she goes into private
practice and writes an amicus brief in
support of a gitmo terrorist she chose
to do that now why did she do that you
know what her answer was she blamed her
law partner yeah so this is just an
excuse-making machine that joe is
nominated to the highest court and i'm
not that impressed she's polished she
can definitely conduct herself well
at this hearing but i don't know if
she's a left-wing loon or she's a
mainstream democrat i have no idea these
people hide their true character very
very well so you don't know what you're
getting but you know when a democrat
nominates a justice that justice never
sides or swings with republicans half
the time these republican nominees they
get in and then they go to the left and
they go to the right and at least i
guess you could say they're independent
maybe but you just get hardcore
stamp it left every single time these
people get nominated so that's probably
what she is i think we can assume that
greg do you oh sorry well i was just
going to say the kavanaugh stuff real
left of just horrible taste in my mouth
remembering what that was like accusing
the guy not only of rape they trotted
out avenatti and accused him of gang
rape right and then if you ask her a
question
about rape
you're then destroyed like this guy
holly they destroy holly for asking
about rape that's all this is anybody
that obstructs a democrat nominee is
destroyed
and if you are a republican nominee then
you're destroying the game if you think
about the amy coney barrett hearings
right remember they the accusation about
her was that she was going to overturn
obamacare and then that and she's
the case comes before in the cases she
rolls on the merits and obamacare is
upheld so all of that but all the things
that amy coney went through where that
was unnecessary yes yes what do you
think
it would this was a powerful uh uh
powerful hearing um i didn't watch it i
didn't see a single
moment of it i had no desire to here's i
mean we know what happens with these
things if you're a republican nominee
you'll be accused of being a rapist if
you're a republican questioning a
democrat nominee you will be called a
racist so either you're a racist or
you're a rapist and these smears only go
one way the worst thing a republican
calls you is that you might be soft on
crime ouch
but should they should they go hard on
her i don't think so you know the
republicans suffer from the gut-felled
law of inevitable failure meaning even
though they know that the outcome will
result in something they don't want
they're gonna do it anyway it's because
you prefer the predictable story
the predictable storytelling loop right
even if you end up on the losing end we
know she's getting confirmed yeah we got
to play our roles we got to waste
everyone's time and set you up for
failure later i prefer to keep your
powder dry right well first i would love
to have a confirmation fast forward
button you know we know the votes are
there so why can't one of the senators
just go push a button and just go okay
we're done already because the bottom
line is you're not rolling over if
you're if you're being polite to her
it's living to fight another day so when
you get an opportunity to nominate
somebody you can look back and you can
go like
this is what we did for yours now try to
do this for us so it's picking your
battles why pick a battle why pick a
battle that you know you're going to
lose you know what it's just a waste of
time just let's get through this move on
to something else you're asking
politicians to turn down an opportunity
to grandstand i know i'm an idiot
there's one other thing that's very
important she's not willing to talk
about her judicial philosophy but she's
willing to talk about her sentencing
philosophy she was on a sentencing
commission for federal statutes and she
said
that she supports the elimination of
mandatory minimum for first-time
offenders who distribute child porn she
does have a philosophy she goes in the
favor of the criminal who's convicted of
possession of trouble why
tell us why it's not going to be a
winning argument against this woman and
she doesn't care about you
but two things really quickly one i
remember no issues about neil gorsuch
first of all who was confirmed at a
highly polarized
well i'm just saying when people say
this is what happens it's not just what
happens and i don't know what would
happen you know if republicans had a
nominee up and they received a letter
and i know the process was completely
terrible congresswoman to dianne
feinstein but that their nominee had
been accused of sexual assault i don't
know what they would do with it but i
would hope that they would consider it
carefully second point when you say we
don't this is how democrats do
republicans so polite they wouldn't even
see merrick garland they wouldn't even
interview the guy go to his office or
have him visit them to hear what he was
all about you see him now though they
had a reason not to see you
i mean what a joke right
yeah we're terrible straight ahead as
russia destroys entire cities president
biden warning about what vladimir putin
may do next hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else